see this I don't have to check if I'm
recording anymore cuz I got one of these
button thingies I just but that's the
noise it makes
Oh how's it going guys now you guys may
or may not know from following my
Instagram that I have me a puppy and if
you're not following my Instagram what
are you doing now you guys know I've
talked about muneca the dog my other dog
which really is my brother's you know we
we kind of take care of them together oh
good girl
always a good puppy what are you saying
like a person she's still like that it's
been a minute let me uh show y'all the
puppy real quick she's sleeping but I'm
awake her the [ __ ] all that topic say
hot puppy say ha say I'm a puppet give
me kiss no you just like every other
[ __ ] I met now for me I haven't had a
puppy in a very long time now my Yulin
when we do have dogs usually a doctor
reason why is because there's a lot of
dogs out there that need homes but
certain people do like specific breeds
me I like all dogs no matter how ugly
stupid or how much they [ __ ] all over
the place now I've had her now for about
a little over a month she was a puppy
that was born for the two dogs that I
have back at home with my parents and
they weren't supposed to have puppies
because we didn't want that [ __ ] to
happen but before we let them neutered
they just you know
that's the noise that old people make
when our people have sex but I basically
forgot just how hard it is to have a
brand new pub because brand new puppies
for lack of better words with stupidest
[ __ ] one of these little bad boys is mad
no I thought one of them was actually
supposed to be a boy salesmen named
Steve you know just because your name a
dog Steve you yelling roll out string
take all girls hit look at them I think
you say hot poppies yeah you know what
the finding of my puppies on no matter
how much of a thug you think you are on
the moment you see one you just crumbly
[ __ ] the boys got a high pitch and
friends don't you know who you are
anymore you know what's funny when
you're a couple and you have a dog the
other person I always like to say oh
it's our puppy really it is only your
dog when you go through the pain take
you to the vet pay for its bills get
scratched all over your necks that's why
I give you cut your nails well I'm
supposed to cut for you but those are
responsibilities that a lot
people don't realize it's like a 14-year
long commitment y'all see that mean
where it says something about dogs how
you may have like three or four meeting
your whole lifetime but I'll only have
one of you hi I'm Sarah McLachlan
please say you'll be the answer for an
innocent animal who's suffering right
now for me it was a very difficult
decision to get another dog because you
know I don't want to be the type of pet
owner that just has a pet just for the
[ __ ] of it you know and you guys do
realize that I do travel a lot I have a
lot of things to do so if I have another
puppy it's just another responsibility
that's gonna pile on to all the other
stuff that I have to do but out of the
litter she was the last one left and she
needed a good home so I decided to take
her in and now look at her she makes me
happy and angry but and the only anger
part that comes in is the fact that she
does not know how to piss and poop on
the pad I want to train her to kind of
pee and poo on the pet so I don't have
to take her out all the time cuz like
the grass in LA isn't really that great
that's a lot of tittie [ __ ] but it
doesn't seem to be happening she doesn't
want to put on grass she doesn't want to
put on the pad she wants to poo on the
floor where she wants so guess what
trying to get shot if you never looked
at your puppy wanted to suck it right in
the face then you option on a pet owner
mmm one time after Jo with that
bitch-ass landlord what they hatin on
this foe she no matter I'm putting in
that work go stretch out that buddy then
I make that Kitty squirt dick just green
tea you put wrong